et bien voilà ce qu'on a vu on a vu
laurent requis et que j'adore et un
certain hugo manos que j'adore
envieraient à deauville bon alors la
semaine avait dit qu'il était à new york
dont qui s'offre une escapade à
deauville avec boingo manos al aire
regarder parce qu'on a on a même c'est
pas moi c'est lui qui le met sur ces tic
toc et ces machins passé mon éthique
tenue pire voilà c'est qui ça c'est ma
mère
on n'est pas en train de se rouler un
patin donc j'ai pas dis ça je dis que
monsieur la semaine à l'air me dit
j'étais à new york avec ruquier cette
semaine je suis à deauville avec truqués
et regarde même plus
l'amitié ça eh ben ils approchent pas
votre ami mais là mais mathieu faut
regarder un peu les magazines paris
match et magazines people il ya écrit
partout laurent ruquier et son compagnon
hugo manos donc empressé vous n'êtes pas
vraiment une mais non en examen une
vraie ou pas ça fait quatre ans mais non
une somme que nous vivons est juif
c'est janvier renseignez vous non mais
tu sais quoi mais pardon de jeu mais
voilà donc je n'y a pas d'infos aussi si
on est observateur et qu'on regarde
l'insta g et les réseaux sociaux du go
on peut voir qu'ils fréquentent beaucoup
des grosses têtes des amis de laurent
ruquier depuis quelques années jean
fiche en scène chantal ladesou
christophe beaugrand ils font du sport
ensemble donc à des petits signaux comme
ça oui enfin je suis désolé tu peux pas
tip-top qu'à côté d'un mec est gaulé
avec des pectoraux toi tu es derrière
ici c'est un fait rare quand évite
d'avoir je dis juste que voilà il fait
partie de donner moi c'est très dur pour
vous je vous promets je suis très
heureux aussi mais je l'avoué moi non
mais ça se voit aussi sa joie mais si
vous voulez commenter nos vies privées
c'est une bonne séquence mois
alors qu'elle conduisait non non non la
seule question je me suis posé en voyant
ça les tic toc break c'est parce que
vous soyez ensemble c'est que moi je
connais un petit peu laurent ruquier
plus il y avait un petit moment il était
toujours assez discret même qu'on te
battre ses vacances dans les grosses
têtes il faisait pas un mot une fois
quelqu'un lui a dit lundi que nos styles
et dit je suis jamais allée mykonos
c'est quelqu'un qui est assez discret et
très bon tout d'un coup ils se
retrouvent derrière un tick tock d'un
mec cadets peck qui ressemble au sein du
jeu je suis très honnête et il ne le
fait pas avec un autre oeil asthme des
secours environ vraiment pas il le fait
parce qu'il vous voit que ça me fait
plaisir et que c'est quelqu'un de
généreux puis qui m'aime mais mais voilà
si non il est pas il n'est pas fou
amoureux de tik tok ni de deux des
réseaux sociaux en général et il n'aime
pas du tout exposer sa vie privée il dit
moi parce que ton frère moi c'est
vrai après si je regarde petit peu
l'émission j'ai le cousin laurent luna
de
ruquier
tu vois jean-michel mais généralement la
reine d'angleterre
regard
m à mon avis il doit être fier de la
relation avec l'os et c'est pour ça
qu'ils se lâchent un peu plus peut-être
que d'accoutumée c'est vrai mais tu as
tout à fait il a toujours assumé le rock
et la politique concerne je commence à
côtoyer juste un petit peu hugo est un
garçon exceptionnel
ouais ouais ouais à talloires sinon abri
dont je pense que laurent ruquier c'est
un dénicheur de talents
mais sa maman qui va lui faire faire un
truc n'a baissé c'est juste une question
il ya un énorme jeu une époque
effectivement voilà cc c'est que
quelques questions la mère de mes thèses
que est ce que comme ça ça me flatte un
peu est-ce qu'il a regardé les deux
premières émissions tout à fait où il a
regardé ai d'ailleurs dit quoi la
semaine dernière il m'a dit et je dis
pas du tout ça pour te faire de la gym
mais il a dit que tu avais été très bon
la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
habib la caméra
je sacré au paddle tir il jeté au paddle
et coutumes a gagné mais la semaine
dernière tu m'as trouvé un petit peu
pour avait inadmissible laurent ruquier
m'a beaucoup peiné
à tout moment je peux filer faire une
chronique là bas laurent ruquier ma
bien-aimée oui c'est que ça fait ma
journée non mais c'est vrai je sais une
des plus belles callas contraire plaisir
c'est là c'est la réalité robin mais
j'attends avec impatience des tic toc
avec laurent ruquier torse nu et human o
son col roulé noir oui
[Rires]
on va taper dessus mais je trouve que
c'est très très bien à d'en parler d'eux
l'assumé parce que c'était tellement
compliqué à l'époque en berne aussi a
fait la une avec son compagnon voilà
c'est génial vous êtes heureux vous
faites un beau couple et si en plus il
aime bien les missions alors là les
ballons d autres parlons d autres
n'auraient pas non bah non du coup alors